according to a study published by the
global think tank cold qual
black americans make up ten percent of
college graduates
yet represent less than one percent of
fortune 500 ceos and only 3.2 percent of
executives and senior level managers
and on average 58 percent of black
people indicated they perceive racism
on the job the non-profit mlt is working
to change that
by building ladders of opportunity to
help people of color gain equal access
to white
collar jobs i categorically would not be
here where i
am today without mlt to hear justin dean
tell it it really
changed my trajectory mlt or management
leadership for tomorrow
secured a success in corporate america
he couldn't have achieved on his own
i was 24 i didn't know which way was up
so i was i had just finished engineering
school a few years ago i knew i wanted
to shift careers i didn't understand
what it took to get those jobs i didn't
understand what it would take to be
successful at those jobs
i didn't even know what it took to get
into business school but with that help
he figured it out
earned an mba and is now partner and
managing director
at boston consulting group i mean it
sounds like a path that i'd like to
ultimately land on
mlt recruit azshara jones will be dean's
intern this summer
a first generation college student at
north carolina a
t she's following the path he blazed
some 12 years ago
it's more than just kind of oh you know
like i have this gpa
or i can speak well or present myself
well it's about
knowing that i deserve to be in the same
room
i can perform just as well as anyone
else because i've had practice doing it
so it's confidence training that's a
part of it i'd say
a lot of clarity and a lot of just
also networking my likelihood of kind of
making it to partner is going to be
so much higher than if i had 20
of my mind is focused on you know am i
fitting in
you know i'm the only i'm the only
person of color kind of in this room
you know am i speaking right am i
talking about the right things
is that really a factor it absolutely is
graduates say mlt provides the playbook
for minority talent to ascend
from college through grad school to the
c-suite it's actually a theory of change
for people of color in america it's the
brainchild of founder
john rice we've taken a page out of the
world of sports
we give people at every stage
the high accountability coaching okay
the playbook to hit the bar
for high performance to get into an
organization to move up and then we
surround folks with a
supportive network of peers and mentors
that actually
gives them those connections that are
critical the social capital
uh that we all know is so important and
guess what it works
last june as the nation called for a
racial reckoning over policing
rice pinned an article in the atlantic
calling for an awakening
in corporate america when the
conversation this country changed
after the deaths of george floyd and a
number of others
white leadership most of them put out
statements
about how much they stand against racism
in all forms which i thought was you
know very powerful
they were shocked and surprised people
of color within their institutions
who told them that the
lived experience for people of color was
completely inconsistent
with the strong statements that
organizations have made white leaders in
particular
realized that they were part of the
problem
the article was inspired by his father
emmett j
rice a ph.d economist and federal
reserve board member
who encouraged both his children to
equalize the system
john's sister is former u.n ambassador
susan rice now tapped to be
president-elect biden's
domestic policy advisor my father
you know who grew up in the 20s and 30s
and the jim crow south
he told me you know that the only way
we're going to change
and really make progress on meaningful
breakthroughs on race is if we
elevate the cost of racist behavior that
ignited a 20-year mission that started
when rice left harvard business school
gave up his lucrative six-figure salary
with the nba
and launched mlt now with 120 corporate
partners
mlt has helped advance the careers of
nearly 10 thousand
students and professionals of color
placing 98 percent of its graduates in
jobs with average salaries above
70 thousand dollars and 75 percent of
their mid-career graduates
are promoted within a year mlt
also launched the career of a future
legend one of the organization's first
hires
a university of pennsylvania graduate
named
john stevens he was looking to
transition
out of corporate life i have to give
back
it's just a requirement to me he walked
up to me and said hey you know johnny
he said i'm trying to pursue a music
career and i'd like to get more
flexibility in my schedule
so i hired him on the spot that analyst
became
john legend
would you say that mlt helped him launch
his career
yeah and he will say that too for those
still working on it
and how do you hope to change the world
how do i hope to change the world
good question that's a very big question
um well i think that first i hope to
change the world by
adding to a company that clearly cares
about the impact that it's making
azshara that was a pretty darn good
answer
is that some mlt training we just saw
there i think it's definitely a little
bit of the mlp special sauce in there
but it's true it's true
she learns fast doesn't she i tell you
you know john rice
you know this notion of of passing it
forward or paying it forward really came
from that dad of his
who who knew who knew some of the the
the secrets to success and he wanted to
make sure that he could offer it to
other people because he
needed it to happen exponentially it
changes the world one
person at a time each person has the
impact and passion numbers are pretty
impressive 10
000 students 98 of them making more than
70k in those jobs
john legend didn't know and john legend